mit dem rücktritt von anne spiegel als
problem aufgetreten und das ist toll ich
wie können wir wie können wir die
zwei kinder als alleinerziehende mutter
verteile dafür genau was ich nur sagen
familienministerin ist die debatte um
termine kürzen wie können wir
in den 90er jahren in der republik
kinder also ich wäre auf jeden fall eine
will am ende ist es tatsächlich auch
die frauenquote jahr wieder voll in gang
verdammt schlimme ministerin ich das gar
großgezogen also das war die arschkarte
hängt es auch von jeder frau ab ja also
gekommen und ich muss zugeben dass eine
nicht werden aber lena du hast ja eine
nummer um es mal ganz so sagen ja das
aussprachen kürzen und wie schützen wir
das kann man glaube ich auch irgendwo
spiegel frauen in der politik und in
nicht so ganz generalisieren ich kenne
tochter ich glaube fünf jahre alt ist
war noch eine zeit wo man rabenmutter so
führungspositionen einen echten
menschen die nicht nur kinder haben
frauen die sie mit einem kind
auf dem gesicht einige städte und keine
deine naja du könntest also laut ich
bärendienst erwiesen hat indem sie
überfordert ich kenne frauen die am fünf
sondern vielleicht auch einen
kita kann
nämlich gezeigt hat wie es nicht geht
kinder und arbeitet nebenbei voll beruf
pflegebedürftigen angehörigen oder
könnte ihn alle drei werden beim
ich hab's gelöst mit 250 prozent einsatz
wie man kind und karriere nicht unter
will ich noch nicht da
ministerium werden was sie denn von
vielleicht ein pferd oder ich weiß nicht
einer familienkutsche er finde ich
ja also punkte gibt da habe ich auch
was ich immer ist ganz egal warum alle
einen hut bekommt das ist schade
wahnsinnig spannend das thema und ich
keine andere lösung wenn man muss dann
menschen haben irgendwelche daten die
ziehe unglaublich meinen hut vor dir
macht man mal was soll man schon machen
generali sie aber ist ja irgendwo ja das
das hat sie einfach maximal tragisch
meisten menschen die ich kenne haben
ja aber wie du das eben gesagt hast ja
wollen weil wir haben ja gerade wechsel
irgendeine verantwortung
schon so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen
finde ich aber ein ganz schönes
gezeigt sie war total überlastet das
schlusswort zu dem thema weil das ist
das fieber beginnt war kein argument
wie du das hättest du hast zwei kinder
es gibt auch aber eigentlich ist das
nicht wirklich im job zu sein ja ich
fünf und sieben jahre als sind sie und
eigentlich das was der richtige ist
hätte einem mann übrigens auch passieren
jeder muss für sich selbst entscheiden
nicht das gleiche nein natürlich nicht
können aber der eindruck ist nun mal
möchte dass keine wünschen was er denn
bis hin zu den fünf und zehn jahre alt
ob man berufstätig sein wie oft man
nicht verändert und das sollte sich auch
hängen geblieben eine frau mit kindern
das war ein scherz muss ich sofort
nicht ob man kinder haben würden jeder
also schon ein halber teenager das macht
zurücknehmen aber es gibt viele menschen
hat es nicht gepackt und das ist
sich gerade einfacher und wir bringen
soll es machen wie er möchte
acer hat sich verändert wenn ich das
schlecht für alle frau mit kindern und
ehrenamtlich sich zum beispiel auch in
die halbe woche hier legt eine rasant
beurteilen kann was heute ja dass zum
ich behaupte diese ganze misere wäre
beispiel eine universitäten frauenquote
der politik ehrenamtlich um andere
schnelle imposante karriere hin während
nicht passiert wenn wir an statt einer
gender gerecht und so weiter es hat sich
dein mann zu hause eingespannt wird und
menschen kümmern und in dem fall muss
frauenquote eine familien quote hätten
ganz viel geändert ich war
er macht das mit erfolg wir haben gerade
frauenbeauftragte an der universität in
die politik einfach die arbeitsweise
dann hätte zum beispiel nur ein beispiel
darüber gesprochen dass man quasi von
muss so gestaltet werden dass es nicht
österreich wo ich war inzwischen dass an
haus aus ja immer erst mal davon ausgeht
24 stunden job ist sondern habe genau um
den universitäten sogar schon so dass
anton hofreiter familienminister werden
die mama macht das alles der papa wird
man zwischen im akademischen und dem
können der hat nämlich einen sohn und
biologischen alter unterscheidet das
sogar gelobt wenn er einmal im büro zu
das würden sich doch eltern viel eher
auch männer können sich ja um
heißt wenn ein kind kriegt man an
einem meeting künstlich kommt wenn das
kümmern und so weiß ich nicht mehr dafür
gleichberechtigung und familienpolitik
rechnungs punkte und so weiter zettel
baby gerade ein bisschen fieber wir
eingesetzt dass wir sehen das problem
waren sind das an und bat ihn aber
kümmern jetzt ist es lisa paus die wird
mütter wir werden gar nicht gefragt wir
einfach jeden teil hinein ist
beiseite was ihnen was ich sagen würde
wir haben keine möglichkeit ich du wir
sich als alleinerziehende natürlich auch
entschuldige dass das problem geht doch
sehr gut kümmern aber diesen ganzen
ist wir müssen es trotzdem auflösen es
alle wir haben keine möglichkeit wir
umweg über an der spiegel hätten wir uns
müssen pünktlich zur arbeit erscheint
geht nicht nur um die politik es geht
nicht nur familien an sondern auch jeden
auch um die finanzen finanzmärkte es
ein federndes kind ist keine ausrede
glaube ich sparen können wenn also schon
menschen also jede person hat auch ins
geht um gehe da wo macht und geld ist ja
eine quote dann bitte eine familien
also meinem job sie würden mit den vogel
privatleben und dieses privatleben
also es geht im prinzip und vorstände um
zeigen während ein mann da quasi noch
quote denn dann würde sich auch endlich
braucht man auch in der politik um
eine kleine runde applaus bekommt wenn
die große unternehmen natürlich sind die
es dann trotzdem scharf ist für die
frauen überall ja die hilfskräfte die
anregungen zu bekommen um andere
der kern des dilemmas vielleicht einmal
familien quote alena
pflegekräfte die krankenschwestern die
meinungen kennenzulernen um nicht nur in
auflösen denn die quote ist ja nur ein
schlecht bezahlten jobs wie auch immer
dieser blase in dieser politik blase zu
um diese frauen kümmert sich ja keiner
ausdruck des problems nämlich der nicht
wie sie in der realität aussehen könnte
aber es geht da wo es sozusagen immer
leben und deswegen finde ich also die
vereinbarkeit von beruf und familie
nicht passt oder klatschten wir am
okay ich habe man müsste sie einfach um
beispiel von frau spiegel ist da wo man
empfehlung dass das nur noch familie
elternschaft hat ja eher karriere tod
ändern dann hätten auch väter die chance
eine erhebliche verantwortung hat
familie zählt bei der berufung in ein
meistens viel verdient meistens viel
also ich aber ohne kinder patricia was
bringt es leider oftmals mit sich oder
prestige hat ja und da ist diese
höheres politisches amt nun auch das
zumindest karriereknick und ich kann
frauengeschichte dann so richtig frauen
jahre chancen weil wir einfach viel zu
habe ich das sah ja wenn wir schon eine
hat sich da frage ich bin reden geht im
in die vorstände frauen in den
unflexibel
quote haben hab ich gesagt dann wäre
finanzmarkt was auch immer das auch in
quote weil eine quote kommt lassen sich
hier sind als braucht also nicht
besser eine familien der heute als eine
den universitäten sind werden längst
zwingend mehr frauen sondern vor allem
auch komplexe behandlung gleich weil ich
frauen die frau die vom spiegel habe es
noch nicht bei zehn prozent ja und da
mehr väter und mütter an der spitze des
dann uns frauen echt ein ei gelegt
ist ein generelles problem da bin ich
staates und den unternehmen familien
eine frau bin deswegen habe ich da ein
dabei dieses problem ist wir lösen ob
weil sie auch so weinerlich war und sie
sicherung des meiner ansicht nach gleich
wir das nur mit einer quote oder mit
bonus dass ich finde die quote überhaupt
zukunftssicherung und dieses motto
einer familienkutsche lösen im zweifel
hat den mann noch die schuld gegeben und
ein totaler unsinn und ich finde man
sollte eigentlich auch in jedem in jenen
ja also ich meinen millionen millionen
zwar geschenkt wir müssen es lösen aber
muss das ganz anders angehen wir müssen
es ist ein breiteres problem und das hat
also sollte ein dreh und angelpunkt in
deutsche mütter und väter haben in der
uns fragen wie arbeitet man in der
ganz viel da bin ich bei ihnen damit zu
jedem unternehmen werden also wir müssen
tun wie wir über den grip den begriff
politik das ist doch die frage es geht
pandemie ihre kinder in irgendeiner form
eigentlich dahin kommen dass diese
der arbeit verstehen was ist arbeit ja
menschenverachtende frage kind oder
sie durchbringen müssen sie unterhalten
doch nicht darum ob jetzt eine verstehen
macht man die heute zu hause oder nicht
karriere dass die obsolet wird und um
und betreuen und die haben das auch alle
jetzt auch nach der pandemie ist ja noch
oder ein verstehe weil mit kind gesegnet
mal anders wie lösen wir das auf wie man
diese frage kümmern sich auch wenn sich
geschah muss oder mate kurz unterbrechen
das jetzt hart anhört frauen ohne kinder
an der spitze steht es geht darum dass
auch wenn didi und hasi
es gibt ja vorschläge ohne ende 32
lebens nun mit der zeit und wir wollen
die politik einfach unmenschliche
kümmern sich um diese frage
stunden woche für frauen elterngeld was
wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr aber eltern
hier nach frau groos meinung hören ob
auch immer ich glaube es ist viel
arbeitsbedingungen teilweise hat weil
werden es tun denn die erleben dieses
passiert es muss noch mehr passieren
sie denn für die familien quote ist also
natürlich fielen also der mann dominiert
aber es ist nicht nur die politik und am
problem ja einfach jeden tag und ich
erst mal würde ich sagen diese
ende glaube ich sind auch individuen las
denke dass sich menschen die betroffen
diskussion hat eine ganz starke
ja noch die politik und der hat endlos
generellen und dynamik ja wir sind beide
sind immer mehr einsetzen werden als
man auch gucken annalena baerbock auch
ich darf das sagen über 50 jahre und
zeit für endlose sitzungen und ich finde
zwei kleine mädchen ja reißt im moment
solche die es vielleicht nicht direkt
jüngere frauen reagieren da ich habe
irgendwie munter durch die
sind und ich höre schon ja ja keine
es geht um es geht darum dass man sagt
weltgeschichte da ist jetzt auch noch